step one I've got my glass  two 25 degree angle swoop in okay now  what did I do wrong first thing you can  do is follow instructions  you're not allowed to do that until you  get it perfect I tried to make Guinness  myself once at home I took a loaf of  pumpernickel bread and put it in the  blender and then buried it in the yard  for about six weeks I got sick as a dog  no you see what men do when they drink  Guinness never look down with a pint  against because it's bad man it's always  look to the Horizon look to the Horizon  pull your elbow up and to pull the  liquid through the head and finding the  glass with my tongue  can you sit underneath the foam  [Music]  [Applause]